good morning everyone
this is the new hampshire house uh
special committee on redistricting today
is the somebody tell me the 27th
and it is we are here for a scheduled
executive session at 10 o'clock before
we begin our work today i'd like you all
to rise and join me in a pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
thanks so much everybody for for joining
me in that and starting our day off with
that
um we have a number of amendments
excuse me we had last week
a public hearing
on amendments
a non-germane amendment to
[Music]
sb200 the purpose of that was to
make it clear that the subject matter of
sb 200 is now redistricting for our
federal congressional districts
there was an amendment proposed last
week
does anybody want to make a motion in
representative barry yes madam chairman
um i would make the motion that that
amendment be inexpedient to legislate
christina i don't have the amendment
number actually in front of me can you
look it up i just looked through my
paperwork
and chair yeah you don't actually need
to vote and experience allegedly no i
know
okay
i know
i i just wanted to make sure that there
was no otp motion
and i'm not seeing any
so but christina just for the record
could you
so 1523 has been um heard and there is
no motion in regards to
1523 which was an amendment to sb 200.
um you have had emailed to you a couple
of amendments amendment
1736 there are copies available for the
public and they were finally posted
online yesterday
there is also another amendment 1702
is there
anyone who would like to make a motion
in regards to 1736
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair i would move to amend senate bill
is there a second
representative marjorie smith seconds it
would you like to speak to your motion
representative bergeron i would thank
you madam chair
um
this is not a new amendment in the sense
that it has been circulated in its
present form since november of last year
it is the amendment that the minority
proposed to house bill 52
and has
been in the public arena for discussion
and for comment for some time
we're reintroducing it because we do
believe that it has the uh it proposes
districts that are competitive and that
minimally disruptive to the current
forms of the congressional districts as
well as disruptive to the residents who
live within those districts
currently the population based on the
2020 census
has
congressional district 1 with 17
945 people
more than congressional district 2
contains
by moving the town of hampstead from
congressional district 1 to 2
that changes the
population deviation to just 51 people
between the two districts
as we've discussed in the past there has
been over
at least since 1880 based on on the maps
that were distributed to us
last week
there has been minor changes made to
congressional districts one and two uh
with each
decennial census and we are proposing to
continue that process and simply move
one town in order to bring the two
congressional districts within a
suitable range of deviation
thank you
further discussion or
comments or questions on the amendment
just before i recognize representative
barry uh representative bergeron you you
gave us the numbers for the deviation
thank you very much it's helpful to have
that on the record what is the
competitive measurement that you
had
i do not have that in my notes okay i
you know i can say that uh
historically in the second district
republicans have won 71 times in the
last 86 elections
and uh over the last eight elections the
first district has changed six times
with the incumbent losing five of those
races
and as so one
one member of this committee has
mentioned in the past results kind of
speak for themselves
thank you
representative barry yes um if uh the
representative will take a question
sure if i can answer it be happy please
do you consider this the least change
method
i do
um
follow it's more of a statement than a
follow-up it's an executive session um
so i don't
um there's actually a way to move less
people and get a lower deviation um
you're moving one town but you're moving
one town but you're not near the perfect
deviation you could move the towns of
campton sandwich albany bartlett hales
and hearts from district one to district
and you would have a deviation of 5
people and 4 people
and that would actually move less people
so you're moving less towns but you're
moving more people so what's your
definition of least change mind would be
moving less people
well mine obviously is moving less towns
fair enough um follow-up madam chairman
representative barry um the
representative mentioned in your speech
we've we've basically made eaten around
the edges since the last
on this map which was came around in
at what point should the state stop
eating around the edges because if the
district that was passed in 1880 which
by the way was done to suppress the
catholic vote
if that district that we're basing
that your map is based off of this
amendment's based off of
if that district was around today it
would be off by around 300 000 people so
for how long for how many more centuries
should we continue to
eat around the edges and not just re
recognize that the population of the
state has shifted
i would say that we have over the last
six months or more looked at a number of
different alternatives to creating
congressional districts and sometimes
after we explore a lot of alternatives
sometimes it makes sense to go back to
one of the initial proposals and find
out that maybe that was the best to
begin with uh
right from the start that's fair um if i
may madam chairman um
before i want to go anybody else want to
go here
okay representative barry question or
general comments
yes this is just general comment um so i
i look at these maps from two
perspectives the first of which is
what's best for the state overall and
what's best for the communities that i
represent of manchester and litchfield
this map um doesn't keep any communities
of interest together other than
the seacoast and for months we have
heard from our friends on the other side
of the aisle about communities of
interest and deviation and
competitiveness
and here we have a map where the
minority party is making the only
district that has gone back and forth in
the last decade
less competitive the town of it's no
it's no um coincidence that the town
they're moving has to be happens to be
ruby red and that they're taking it out
of the only district that has been won
by the other party in the last 10 years
so the competitiveness argument just
doesn't fly on face value you're
actually making the maps less
competitive
the communities of interest argument
that your party has pushed for the last
six months is completely bankrupt at
this point the only
community of interest you're keeping
together is the
seacoast so as a manchester person as a
i-93 person which is the center of the
state's population why would i support a
map that breaks apart my community so
that we can keep things the same as
they've always been which they're not
because 1880 was 120 years 140 years ago
um
and we just keep making things the same
and we keep sacrificing every other part
of the state has to be sacrificed so
that the seacoast can be kept together
i don't understand how anybody from the
greater manchester area could support
this our community is divided litchfield
is not in there um i don't underst you
know they you they bring forward the
let's take a drive you know oh from uh
well let's take a drive let's take a
drive now you go if you start in salem
you go to pittsburgh you're going to
switch districts five times
this is ridiculous at what point are we
hitting the reset button at what point
do we just keep eating around the edges
and in 120 years there's somebody like
me sitting here saying the same thing
we're going to keep eating around the
edges
the population has changed it's 300 000
people different from what they passed
the map that this is based off of no one
refutes this was designed to suppress
the catholic vote
for everything that we've heard for all
the virtue signaling and the gnashing of
teeth and the hair pulling
it's it's all just bankrupt this map was
built to to suppress the catholic vote
you're building a map off of a map that
was built to suppress the captain vote
it doesn't keep communities of interest
together it's it's it's a laughable
argument it's not a least change method
it can be done by moving towns in the
north country i don't know why the north
country always gets gets thrown aside
but i will not be supporting this for
obvious reasons but these things need to
be said you know they um they they say
you can do whatever you want on your
last day and this is the last day of our
meeting and i'm gonna say it
thank you representative barry for
clarification i just wanted to let the
committee know that i inquired as to
what that little leg was that
representative smith
and apparently it's a census block
without any population other than clams
so
i don't know they haven't come up to the
surface to let me know so
but that it is very disconcerting when
you look at it as to what are we talking
about but that is apparently thank you
and of course we do not do redistricting
by census block but of course the
programs include it because the debt
because quote the data the the
the block is there so representative
especially
thank you manager um no worries i was
gonna say i need a i'm representing
difficulty today
and i mean i will be supporting
amendment uh 2022 1736 i h i think you
know making sure that
we keep north the north kind of the
interest of the north country in
um
that each district has a little bit of
that is important i think when we think
about those communities of interest
that's that's important um i think the
other you know one of the other things i
i
really for voters um
is making sure they're not as confused
you know when we make drastic we shift
around maps and make drastic changes
people for
don't realize who their new
congressional representative is they
might have had previous relationships
with them doing constituent services
i've done constituent services with my
people um with one of the
members of the federal delegation and
people you know they like to know okay
this is where the office is if i have a
case with the va this is where i go and
so when you start switching things
around and say oh you're no longer under
you know cd1 you're now in cd2 you're
gonna start missing out on that so you
know i think least change also has has
an effect on our voters
further comments representative mcguire
yes thank you i'm opposed to this map
for a couple of different reasons one is
so in the case of merrimack county
there is one town that's in cd1 and the
rest of us are in cd2
which means that
we're split we
we don't get the coherent advantage
of having the county treated as a unit
also the cut the idea that the north
country is in two districts is i think
a little disingenuous i think this north
country should be in one district
because it is a fairly cohesive
community of interest and you'll notice
that the
the white mountains are
are in cd1 and in coast counties and cd2
or most of it
so you've got everything split up
there's no i and i would also like to
comment to the representative from
manchester that my constituents don't
seem to know or care who their
congressional
uh delegate is
they write me letters telling me to vote
in congress and when i tell them you
have to talk to your congressperson
which at the moment is representative
custer
they say who's she
they
most people are not involved with their
federal delegation i have not gotten
good constituent service and neither has
anybody else who's talked to me they
have frequently said well
my congress person ignores me so i went
to the senator and the senators don't
care what district you're in they've got
the whole state
and so i think that unless we have
unless we manage to elect
representatives who are
much better at constituent service
than any of the people i've seen
it doesn't matter who your congress
person is
thank you
further questions or comments
representative marjorie smith
thank you madam chair um representative
uh
barry noted that the original um map of
1880 was drawn specifically
to discriminate against a particular
religious group and
i was not aware of that and i thank him
very much for sharing
that information
i would like to take this opportunity to
point out that um
that was of course um
drawn
assuming
as i i'm sure it's true
having to do with catholic males
since in 1880
no female
could vote and in fact for
basically another 40 years
there were no
females at all and that is a group that
i think everybody would agree
has some importance in
the electoral process in in the current
year
um and what
uh
my point
is that things change
and we have to figure out how to address
change
um i also want to point out that never
never
was any party other than the republican
party
in charge of drawing
district lines for congress
for the executive councils for the new
hampshire senate and the new hampshire
house
so that every map
that was drawn let's just go from 1881
we ended up with two districts before
that the districts uh
there were three and there were four for
other reasons
um and those
districts that were drawn
were drawn by a republican majority
that respected the principle that we
build on that which
has gone before
that includes having two major
[Music]
supreme court cases
that among other things established one
person
one vote
of course in the vernacular referred to
was one man one vote but i'd like to go
back to my first point about women
and i think that each of the
republican majorities every 10 years
since 1880
recognized that the state has been here
for a long time
that
things change our population changes the
concentration changes
but we do not
operate from a blank slate we do not go
back
and pretend that nothing that has
happened before matters and now we're
going to begin again
those of us who
respect the principles of
and i think all of us do but in
different ways
of a democratic society realizing that
the power
that we have comes from the people who
elect us
i believe that that stability is
important
and i um strongly support this
particular
amendment which
respects that which has gone before
respects the republican leadership which
we have had
for the last 140 years in this state
and at the same time understands the
changes that have taken place in the
population concentration
um i also would suggest to you
that there are when you talk about
communities of interest there are
differences in community interest
between for example the connecticut
valley
and what you refer to as the seacoast
um
but when you look at a map
that tries to bring together
for reasons that aren't necessarily
obvious
the entire western
side of the state with the entire
eastern side of the state
one wonders about
this this argument about communities of
interest
thank you very much
madam chair thank you representative
smith before i take any further comment
i would like to
share with the committee that i went
through the exercise of looking at other
states that only have two congressmen i
think there are four of us
and i would submit to you that we
actually have a harder job than the
states who have three or four districts
because it is more difficult to get
lines or groupings that you can get a
consensus of agreement on i'd also like
to point out to representative smith's
comments about changes
if you were to do this
simply on population and argue that the
biggest driver of interest in this state
is the southern border because that's
certainly where our growth has come come
from
the line for population deviation would
not be north of manchester straight
across the state it would be visually it
would look like about one or two town
deep across the bottom so
i just want to publicly point out that
this committee has had a difficult task
in a couple of ways representative steve
smith
thank you madam chair
i know it's stereotypically new england
to say always done it that way before
but i've always rejected that and i've
seen a lot of actual harm done by it
i live on the vermont border and the
giant expanse of cd2
i have multiple grievances with the
existing districts and and this one as
well it doesn't solve any of my problems
first of all if you want to talk about
gerrymandered we're normally thinking of
how do i pack members of political
parties into different municipalities
there's another way to do it to protect
incumbency look at this map how do you
campaign cd2
you're advertising in boston
the keen sentinel wcax out of burlington
wptc out of plattsburgh you're going to
have to also do wmur it's an incredibly
expensive district
this doesn't change it it doesn't solve
the problem and i wish it did
we have a road our main thoroughfare on
the western border of the state
literally sliding into the connecticut
river that's not even hyperbole
hyperbole it's actually what's happening
people there are sick of hearing about
i-93 expansion and that's where all the
highway dollars are going it doesn't
matter what party they're in this is
what i hear from people they're not even
political people in some cases but they
all agree
this doesn't help that problem of having
a congress person that will help us
focus
on just the issues with impact to the
river and getting that fixed up
it's a mess
why don't we just start over when when
the 1880 map was done what was the
industry i don't know
i do know that in the 35 years i lived
in new hampshire and sullivan county
i've seen a change drastically it used
to be along the river
a major manufacturing area
everything from boots to photo albums
across the river
gears
in sunapee we had precision machine
which back in the day used to make
precision parts for missiles
all of that's gone
and that's just in the 35 year window
that i've had to look so how the heck
the decisions that were made over 100
years ago when we have that kind of
rapid change going to a service economy
pretty much but how do we let that drive
our decisions today
i agree with representative berry it's
time for a new ground up approach to
address not the new hampshire of 1880 or
1920 but of the state it is in today
so uh this is too much same old same old
for me and for that reason alone i
couldn't possibly support it
thank you further questions
representative espedeza
thank you madam chair and just to that
point i don't you know we're talking
about 1920. this map is probably the
most similar to 2010 like this is our
sorry 2012 when it was when it was done
so we're not talking about you know i
know you brought up the century old 1880
shape but we're talking about this map
was done 10 years ago similarly and so
and and then similarly was done again in
2002 it hasn't really changed shape so
when we're asking you know folks if
they've you know that they've done a bad
job with are we saying okay so the last
last two times that this has gone
through
like that they make a big error and you
know are we claiming that back then that
that's what they did um
you know i
i am sympathetic to to the fact that you
know this was done to split
the the catholic vote as as i'm catholic
myself
and i would say that people like myself
probably would also not have been
allowed to vote back in the 60s so um
somebody that looks like me um so i
think you know that it in and now you
know you have two districts that have
two of the largest population centers in
the state you have the city one has
manchester city two has nashua
so and i think that the demographics of
it actually help help both districts i
think having um you know diverse
populations and both are are is good for
is good for it so you know just as if
you know making sure that the north
country is well represented making sure
that we have uh diverse demographics uh
racial and ethnic demographics in each
district is important too so
once again that's why i'm supporting
this map
further discussion representative barry
thank you and i i thank you for my
fellow representative from manchester
for bringing that up and um uh for
representative uh me for using your
first name national nashville i'm sorry
you are from national i apologize um
the uh
we can't have the two of you yeah we
can't have we're too close together i
you're kind of making my point the two
representatives you're kind of making my
point for me which is why are we basing
a map off of
at the time when people of color would
not be allowed to vote and women would
not be allowed to vote
we keep making changes that's still at
the at the end of the day you're coming
back to
state you're making statements that
ultimately support my argument which is
we are making a least change method
we're making least change on a map
that was built for nefarious purposes
at a time when voters were being
actively suppressed based on their
gender and the color of their skin
when do we hit the reset i keep asking
when do we hit the reset button when do
we hit it is it in 10 years and and i
respect the fact that republicans have
drawn the districts it's not a it's not
an invalid argument but if anybody's
ever followed me knows i don't stand up
for my party when it does wrong things
in fact i catch a lot of flack for it um
because i pointed out i'm uh
if you're looking for an example i've
advocated for eq for equal marriage for
10 years in my party and i get beat up
for it at times and i'm going to keep
doing it because it's the right thing to
do i don't stand up for when people do
bad things they did a bad thing in 1880
they should have changed it in 2010 they
should have changed it the moment
we realized hey like we shouldn't draw
districts around religious minorities
like they should have done it then but
we have the opportunity to do it now so
why not
further discussion or questions on this
the amendment before us is amendment
it is an amendment to sb 200. if there's
no further discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
roll this rule
this vote is on an otp motion
on amendment 17 1736
thank you madam chairman
uh representative of steven smith no
representative turcotte
no
representative mcdonald votes no
representative lynn
no
representative barry no
representative gagne
no
representative marjorie smith
yep
representative bergeron yes
yes
representative piedra
yes um
okay
representative espicia
yes
representative hegan phillips
representative tolowsky yes
representative griffin
no
bail seven to eight
the motion on amendment number 1736
has failed is there another motion for
the committee representative barry
yes ma'am chairman we're moving on to uh
my amendment correct so i've got my
parliamentary procedure correct it's up
to what you mean
one thing for the record madam chairman
uh representative uh i made a motion
earlier and representative turcotte
seconded we didn't debate that it'll
motion so i'm just going to for the
recommended withdrawal i was going to
ask you at the end of the session
representative turcotte withdraws a
second
sure thank you thank you sir just just
to keep things clean the clerk has
pointed that out to me
um yes madam chairman um i would like to
move excuse me i don't know there we go
almost almost recommended representative
bergeron's amendment again i'm sure that
would have been fun uh
i would like to move um uh amendment
2022-100
uh to sb200 as ought to pass and i will
speak to my motion
it's been seconded by representative
mcguire representative barry you're
recognized okay so
we've been on this process now for how
long we've done this for a while six
eight months now right um and what have
i what have we heard
from
basically everyone who has testified we
want
similar communities together you guys
call them communities of interest we
want similar communities together
we want
a district that respects
political existing political boundaries
here's county alliance we want districts
that have a low deviation
we want districts that make sense
so
here's what i did
i gave you exactly what you asked for
i kept every economic community together
that wasn't already divided by a county
line
i kept county line i use county lines
because that is how the federal
government distributes money
i don't agree that that's how the
federal that's how the
government should distribute money but
that is how they distribute money so
here we have a map
that keeps eight out of the ten counties
entirely together
it keeps every economic community
together
it prioritizes
the population center of the state which
is the i-93 economic quarter if you've
ever looked at a population map of new
hampshire that is the largest
population center of the state the
second largest by the way is the sea
coast
our current map
prioritizes the seacoast and then
divides the i-93 economic corridor
sacrificing the largest population
center of the state for the sake of a
smaller one
it's time that that ends
as representative as the representative
uh smith said um steve smith sorry for
using your first name represented but
it's two smiths today
um
it's time that the communities
that have similar interests are able to
effectively advocate it and it's time
for communities that aren't there to be
able to have their their word too
if you live in the north country
you are currently divided
that changes now your voice is stronger
if you live in the valley
your devi uh your voice is now no longer
diluted
by the lakes region
this puts the communities together
it puts the center of the state's
population together it has the lowest
population deviation of any map publicly
presented that i am aware of if someone
has one that gets it lower than four and
five please bring it to me i would love
to see it
and i did this
i did this so that the people who have
made the arguments for communities of
interest
and political boundaries
can explain to me why they oppose this
and i knew what they would do
i knew what they would do i knew they
would oppose it because once again their
arguments are bankrupt i knew they would
immediately go to competitiveness this
ubiquitous term that on last friday i
asked people testifying define that
define competitive i'm a numbers guy i
got started in data i still program
computers to this day
i work with data i look at numbers
no one
no one has been able to define it and
with respect to the member from nashua
he was asked earlier even he didn't have
it in his notes to define it
i have said it time and time again
i look at outcome
so
i asked last friday the quote fair maps
people
what do you use as your benchmark for
competitive and there wasn't a real
straight answer but we did get a data
point out of it which was we look at the
2020 election
so i built this map not based on
politics
i kept county lines and commun economic
communities together
and then i said what is the 2020 outcome
because that is what the quote fair maps
people said
the republican would have won by 300 and
some odd votes
50.05 percent
and yet here we go
that's not competitive 50.05 percent is
not competitive
with the standard that they set
you want to keep counties together
current map splits five this one splits
two
the map you just proposed splits five
counties
no economic community is split
it's got the lowest deviation i look
forward
to your objections to this map other
than it's not what we currently have
i look forward to it i literally woke up
this morning i don't know if i'm looking
for today because we'll see what happens
in the long run but i am i am excited
for the shamelessness
of communities of interest in county
lines and and competitiveness
here's your map the problem is you got
exactly what you wanted i gave it to you
and now we're going to oppose it so
madam chairman like i said 8 out of 10
counties are kept together every
economic community is kept together
it recognizes the the shift in
population from the current map the
current maps design like i said is 300
would be 300 000 off it was passed today
this one's off by four and a half people
it meets all of the legal and
constitutional requirements of both the
united states constitution and the new
hampshire constitution and i look
forward eagerly look forward to this
debate
thank you representative barry i do have
to say my mind has wandered to what my
day would look like if you were really
really looking forward to it
um representative bergeron thank you
madam chair and
i certainly don't want to disappoint the
representative from the litchfield in
manchester so i would be happy to object
to some of the
uh issues he raised with with some
questions and i'll focus on the two
areas that he highlighted as being very
interested in that is numbers and
outcome
so let me start with numbers
uh representative barry in
arguing against the previous amendment
we discussed you indicated that moving
one town and 9 000 people
was too high based on another
alternative you had in your back pocket
however this proposal that you put
before us would move approximately 460
000 people from 73 towns from one
district to another
representing about a third of the
population of new hampshire
could you explain how you can condone
that kind of population disruption based
on your early argument that there should
be minimal change in population and
townships correct so i'm happy to do
that actually because senator barry
you're recognized because i didn't make
that argument
your side made that argument your side
advocated for lease change
that was not my argument in fact i just
spent grandiosing for five minutes about
how i think least change is pretty
messed up
so
i start with a blank slate i don't build
districts around politicians i haven't
in none of the maps that i have drawn
personally have ever built around a
politician if you followed me on any
times in election law i i have horror
incumbency advantage
i actually tried to reform the finance
laws so that it was reduced
you're the side
that wants to use least change
you're respectfully representative and
i'll address this to the speaker to the
to the chairman
i am not the one trying to use a map
from 1880 that was designed to suppress
catholics as my base map
i'm using a map
based on county lines
and economic communities to make my map
i didn't suggest lease change
i suggested a map that represents new
hampshire
further question man i'm sure
representative bergeron
thank you representative barry
during this committee's consideration of
redistricting redistricting proposals
for senate districts and executive
council districts sponsors or members of
this committee uh argued that incumbency
was in fact a concern in some of the map
drawing that was being done
uh in this proposal
um
and i recognize that you already
mentioned that incumbency wasn't
necessarily a concern
you move representative custer and
representative pappas into the same
congressional district could you explain
your rationale for doing so
um correct so my right representative
barry you're recognizing thank you ma'am
i'll try and i'll try to get the
recognition first correct as i said i
didn't consider incumbents and
candidates if you'll notice uh
representative there are in my proposed
map members of my own party
running
in a district drawn out of this district
you know why because i didn't consider
politicians when drawing my map
and your reference to the state senate
and executive council map representative
i didn't draw those they are presented
to me as effectively binary options
i was the primary driver of this map
so i drew it like i wanted it to be and
i do not draw districts around
incumbents i do not draw districts
around politicians if that's a priority
of your party
that's fine it is not mine
one final question if i may
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair
um
representative barry i don't think it's
necessarily just a concern of my party
and i think you already alluded to this
and your most recent response
your proposal would move
um
out of congressional district one
the candidates tim baxter gail huff
brown
mark kilbane
and
carolyn levitt from the republican
primary in congressional district one
into congressional district two
thereby probably
almost ensuring that candidate matt
mowers uh will win that seat
go ahead
was your
intent
to do that to redistrict in such a way
that you would be favoring one
congressional candidate over another
representative barry i waited thank you
um absolutely not
my point of drawing this map was one
that would best represent the state of
new hampshire
it is not my fault
that three
you mentioned a candidate i've never
heard of and i apologize um but
that three of the candidates are in the
seacoast it's not my fault it's not my
fault that the seacoast is in the other
congressional seat
they react i didn't factor in any
any
candidate
and the notion
that
i should have drawn districts around
candidates running today
for the next 10 years
is insane
you draw a district that best represents
the state i do not draw districts around
candidates and politicians i've never
done it
the caucus will tell you i've never done
it i don't do it
if your party wants to advocate for that
if you want to advocate for drawing
districts for the next 10 years based
along
hypothetical candidates today which by
the way there's no federal rule you can
run in a seat you don't live in i
believe congressman maxine waters does
not live in her congressional district
and i believe she's a leader of the
democratic party
never been a problem
i drew this district specifically to
give you exactly what you asked for
it's not my fault you don't like what
you asked for thank you representative
barry um just for clarification for
people who don't know representative
berry is absolutely correct and sort of
goes back to my point about
these districts being difficult to deal
with on a state you do not
for the federal congressional offices
need to reside in the district
we currently have a candidate for cd2
um who does not reside in cd2
um so
it does sort of um raise the issue as to
your representation are you doing it for
the district or the state representative
marjorie smith
thank you madam chair before i i
begin i would like to register my
distress
at words like bankrupt and insane
when
we are a deliberative body we where we
are expected in a in a civil way
to exchange deeply held views but i
personally believe we can do that
without using
terms that
are clearly meant to be offensive
i would like however if i could
representative smith thank you for your
comment i i
would hope that no one is ascribing
personal motive to any member of this
committee i would like to thank all of
the members of this committee because i
have not taken that i will tell you as
an as a former attorney i have just
retired
um
bankrupt has a meaning and it is quite
useful in a descriptive term and um i'm
sure that the representative is
sorry that you might have taken offense
from the term but as a chair i did not
so i would have ruled it out of order if
i did so thank you very much for
bringing that to our attention you can
continue
thank you i notice you didn't mention
insane i couldn't remember the other
word and frankly that's directed at me
so often during the course of a day i
certainly didn't take anything from that
um
thank you very much i wonder if um
the member could help me understand the
community of interest between for
example
so yes i'm i'm i describe that in my and
first of all representative i would i i
do have genuine respect for you we sat
together at the hillsborough county um
hearing session and i generally enjoyed
that time together that was not meant to
offend you and if it did i am sorry i do
mean what i said but i did not mean it
in a defensive way um to answer your
question about what do these two groups
have together
currently
they are smaller than the main economic
and population center of the state
that's what they have in common they're
not the i-93 economic quarter which is
actually over half of the state but you
can't get more than half of the state
into one district so that's what they
have in common
i hear this and i alluded to this at the
beginning which is you know everybody
wants to think east west but nobody
thinks north south
and currently if you start in salem and
you drive to pittsburgh new hampshire
you come in and out of the district five
times and i would also
proposition you this what does salem
have in common with pittsburgh new
hampshire what does portsmouth how is
portsmouth the same as manchester i live
on the south side of manchester it's a
working class community portsmouth is an
upper class affluent community we're not
the same we're in the same district
this is about putting districts together
that best prioritize the whole state and
in this map that i've proposed
the two districts you say you mentioned
you mentioned hampton and westmoreland i
believe
will have a better chance of influencing
their congressmen instead of just being
drowned out by
nashua or the i-93 corridor or whoever
whatever is
whatever is i understand nash was in
this but
by what i meant is a larger economic a
larger community they have the
opportunity as an economic community to
be on a more equal playing field
and that's why it's done like this
that's why i put the largest economic
community together so that their
interests are focused on and that the
other smaller economic communities like
representative smith smith the other
representative smith can have a voice
like the north country can stop being
divided and have a larger voice and an
impact on the outcome and their
congressmen that's why it's done like
that
thank you i would just like to point out
and
representative specia right after i'm
finished um
i sort of look at this map and even
though we're talking about new hampshire
redistricting i think of the license
plate of maine which says vacation land
um because the north country the
seacoast and the west part of the state
are certainly uh vacation destinations
um for people coming in from out of
state um representative espisia
well i mean
i think nashville is a great vacation
place and we'll take it from name there
you go but um i have just a question for
representative very i know you talked
about splitting the catholic vote
earlier so why is you know national
manchester why are we still splitting
them up and
um
and yeah i just you know why are you
continuing this pattern yep um i'm sorry
i wait for my follow-up i'll wait for my
recognition i'm sorry thank you the last
time i let you go right yes you're
recognized representative thank you so
uh that's a great point and i i figured
it would be raised um the difference is
i'm not designing a map
to do that
i went to catholic school i'm not
catholic myself
but i went to catholic school i wouldn't
design
a map that would try to disenfranchise
what was basically every friend i had in
high school
so that's the difference it's not
designed to do that the stated interest
of this map is the i-93 economic
corridor that's the state interest
stated in interest in 1880 was making
sure the catholics couldn't swing an
election
and i by the way i also don't know where
the major catholic populations are
anymore they probably are manchester
nashua they probably are but my
understanding is i think actually the
plurality of the state is now catholic
um it may be a majority so if it is i'm
sorry but if it's probably a plurality
at this point so drawing a map that
would disenfranchise the catholic vote i
think at this point would be impossible
but it wasn't the intention in drawing
it and that's the difference in tensions
matter
i'm
i've seen no more red lights or hands
representative lane
um
thank you madam chair
i i don't understand the continual
reference to the 1880 map
because the map has changed over 140
years the map that we are redoing is the
2012 map
not the 1880 map so
i don't understand all these references
to the 1880 map and the 300 000 people
and whatever
what we're focused on today is the 2012
map and the maps that have come before
us over the past eight months
so it's just a comment because it it
that doesn't re that doesn't convince me
of anything i don't know how convincing
that point is what's convincing are the
other points that you have made
but i also
i do think there's something to be said
for such radical change
for people
particularly in my district but also i
don't comment this as representing the
people
of merrimack
of my district merrimack 12 which was
ward 2 of concord i come at this looking
at it is this the best for the entire
state so i reference back to your
comment about you look at this as how to
help the people of manchester i look at
i look at this as what's best for the
people of our state is it better to
totally redo and move over i can't
remember the exact number of them
or is it better to move one town and i
still come down on the side of moving
one town
because when we heard comments
uh and the ten counties that we went to
nobody said
please redo the whole thing we want you
to start from zero you know we never
heard that comment
um
and that's really the only real comments
that i have
thank you representative lane
representative steve smith
thank you madam chair um to answer the
question why we keep talking about the
1880 maps because i think it was at our
very last meeting that we were presented
with the 1880 maps and subsequent maps
in the middle to build a case
that we have always had a policy i don't
know who we are but
the people doing redistricting over 100
years started with that and based it on
that and we're talking about it because
we're trying to indict that argument
that was made before this committee that
that is the proper course forward we we
disagree with that
so that's that's why we're responding to
the 1880 map
um the amendment that's before us
well it didn't solve my problem of cd2
being you know a horrific mess
and hard to campaign
you solve the other problem though with
this one
i will have new hampshire will have one
representative who will care deeply
about i-93 who will probably have a
tattoo somewhere that says i-93 because
that's what they're going to live and
breathe
and what i get out of it
is a representative that never has to
think about 93. so at least thank you
for solving one of my problems and it's
a big one
further questions representative lynn
i just want to make a comment um i
as representative barry pointed out
earlier
a great deal of the focus prior to today
from our friends on the other side of
the aisle was the lack of competitive
competitiveness of prior proposals
representative barry has made it seem
what seems to me to be a pretty
compelling argument about the
competitiveness of these of
of the proposal he's presented now and
interestingly i haven't heard any
anything from our friends on the other
side of the aisle to contradict that in
any way to say that oh no he's wrong the
competitiveness is something different
than what he proposed so i leave the
question if uh if competitiveness is
important to you and it seems to me you
should vote for representative barry's
proposal
thank you representative lynn
representative mcguire thank you madam
chair
to representative stephen smith's
comments
the trouble with having only two
districts is that if you have one that
is coherent and focused that means the
other district is everybody else there's
no other way around it you can either
have two
scattered districts
or you can make a one coherent district
based on
a principal
and then the other district has to be
everything else in the state
and that's just a matter of of the
numbers and the way we're split you can
make your split any way you like
but you can't have two coherent
districts
when the state itself is not coherent
representative espicia
so in terms of competitiveness i mean
we've made cd2 even more even less
competitive we've made it significantly
less competitive so i don't you know i i
mean yes
great we've made cd1 very competitive a
cd we've basically thrown away cd2 and
said you know what cd2 you're basically
gonna win um with this kind of map
um and you know i i love sports i'm a
big sports guy and i will also say
though like the map that was presented
that with uh my colleague from nashville
presented
it
it keeps our districts competitive and i
will also just add that you know i just
i saw the boston celtics game and they
were what an eight seed and they beat
the number one seed had the the brooklyn
nets who were supposedly the gonna be
the winners of of of the nba
championship this year so you know just
because you know you you have this
competitive edge doesn't mean it's it's
a forego you should just give it up
thank you for that comment i'll just
point out that um during the course of
our review of material as i recall we
had a
an analysis of the current cd2 that had
a
uh
competitiveness swing to one side of
over i think nine percent
um and it was identified as a liens
to one side i don't know any political
measure that finds nine percent a mere
leaning so
i agree that cd2 unfortunately
um has as representative smith steve
smith might say has had one problem
taken care of representative barry and
then representative yes um happy to
address that for you representative i'm
from nashua excuse me
i'm gonna i'm not gonna live that down
am i no i didn't think so
how many times has the current cd2
changed hands in the last under the
current map
the answer is zero
none
it's not competitive now
what it appears and
i'm gonna address this to the chair
because i don't wanna single out
remember what it appears madam chairman
my friends on the other side's
definition of competitive is this is
a system where they win every time both
districts
that's effectively what it is that
that's the argument that they're making
um
and it's a fair argument you know that
they've had success at the top of the
federal ballot over the last not just 10
years but 20 years it's it's it's just
once again it's just math right just
numbers results i'm a results guy
but this is what i look
at over the last 10 years roughly
46 to 47 let's just help my argument say
47 of the state has voted reliably for a
republican candidate on a federal level
and we have zero representation we have
no shot
we have no shot we make arguments about
oh if you make cd2 on competitive
republicans you're gonna stop voting
it's meant to you know scare us to not
support it's not it's already not
competitive it's already there
you know it's there i mean i know you
won't say i'm sure i know they won't say
it
but they know it um
this is not a map that locks in a
republican victory it doesn't it does i
just told you 50.05
is not a lock
what it does is it gives republicans a
chance
and if we're talking about outcome and i
just mentioned the last 20 years but i
like to talk about the last 10 because
that's the current map
it's fair that the other side would have
a reliably
a reliable district the voters have said
that's what they want
but to ignore the 47 percent of the
state
that wants something else and to say no
you can never have anything
under some subjective term of
competitiveness it's
it's it's ludicrous it's ludicrous this
is not a map that locks a republican in
you can't draw one by the way the most
extreme example i was able to make
had a republican winning with 53 percent
of the vote the most extreme example you
can't make it the population of the
state does not allow for it
this is a district
that a republican can win not a
republican will win
and to your point representative
sometimes the eighth seed will knock out
the one seed
and if that means a republican happens
to win in cd2 with a disadvantage
god bless him and that's the will of the
voters but it's time that
one party have a chance we have a chance
not a lock
we rejected a lock
the governor rejected a lock he said
don't do it he rejected a lock
this is not a lock this is a chance and
there's a difference representative
talersky
thank you madam chair um
i thank the committee for giving me the
chance to participate in the discussion
uh we we thank you for being willing to
come back
that's always i think a good sign thank
you um i just wanted to comment quickly
i'm hearing from the representative
about how
the map
includes
the
cd1 with the the economic um
community there around 93 um and then it
was referred to cd2 being everything
else or a vacation land and um i guess
also coming from nashua
i have a little bit of problem with that
description um with nashua being an
economic
engine for this state also and the fact
that
although i love her she is not vacation
land so
i don't actually believe that um either
of those those comments actually do
apply to the map but um i think that the
state might be better served
with understanding uh
two
districts that can represent the diverse
communities from the north country all
the way down to the diverse uh
economic drivers uh in the south but
perhaps having them be a bit more
balanced um
i just wanted to share that thank you
thank you
i think this discussion highlights what
the committee heard in hearings that
regardless of the districting the
population of the state makes it
difficult to do
um as
some of you were with our hearings in
the north country where we heard about
how they wanted more representation but
the population is what it is so we have
to work with the numbers that's where
they are presented representative barry
so uh to address this because
representative representatives media as
well um into this it's a kind of the
question to answer grounds why is it
nashua in this down there with it um and
the answer is it's population deviation
um when i released my letter to the
chair which i do hope you read if you
don't i'm happy to provide you with a
copy i listed three tiers of criteria
the first one is deviation population
deviation and i just could not find a
way
and if if you find a way please bring it
forward to me but i could not find a way
to
keep it keep nashua into
the i-93 corridor district without just
imploding the district
um it's just it's once again it's a
factor of
of where people live in the
concentration in which they live um but
i did to to reduce it i did make an
attempt to do it i actually i did make a
good faith effort i just was not able to
get it done
representative lane
um
thank you madam chair
i i would like to point out
when we talk about competitiveness
between the two districts that a lot of
it has to do with candidates and not
necessarily
the party from which that candidate is
from and i think a good example of that
is the governor
he won both cd1 and cd2
i think our current congress people
are strong candidates and that is why
the
the majority party is not successful in
those districts
so
i would offer that they are still
competitive districts but perhaps
we have stronger candidates for those
two races and you have stronger
candidates for other races rather than
thank you
further questions or comments we are
discussing amendment 2022
h
anything further from committee members
i'm sure representative bergeron just
the question of the sponsor of the
amendment representative barry you
indicated that you had three criteria in
drafting this uh he's mentioned the
first one was deviation could you tell
us what the other two criteria were uh
yes so i had uh to answer i'm sorry
madam chairman i i keep stepping over
here no i apologize uh go ahead
representative barry um i have three
tiers of criteria i had more than three
criteria
so the tier one criteria was actually
two criteria which was an extremely low
population deviation and do not split
any cities or towns um obviously those
were accomplished
so the the tier two criteria
was keeping county lines together as
much as possible
as well as recognizing
economic communities
and i stated in the letter once again
i'm happy to provide it to you that
generally speaking trying to balance
those two together i didn't divide an
economic community that wasn't already
divided by a county line
and a really easy example of that is
belknap county and carroll county the
count the towns of tuftonboro wolfeboro
and moultonborough are all lake towns on
lake winnipesaukee but they're divided
by the carroll county line i didn't draw
the carroll county line
that was drawn i think in the 1700s
so that was my tier 2 criteria my tier
three criteria was competitiveness
because that was something that i heard
from uh in the governor's veto message
or he hasn't vetoed it yet but in the
governor's message to us was he didn't
believe it was competitive so i wanted
to address that um and that and that's
why i released that's why on friday i
asked the fair maps people
what the definition of competitive was i
asked the league of women voters what
the definition of competitive was the
only thing i got out of them was we used
2020 so i used 2020 and i released the
data along those lines one further
question representative bergeron i thank
you representative barry for that
clarification
then i guess my last question is what is
your definition of competitiveness
so representative barry
[Music]
um
my definition of competitive is a result
that would actively reflect the nature
of the state and as i said earlier the
other party has had great success
federally for the last 10 to 15 years
this does not produce a map that would
produce a 50 50 parity this is a map
that republicans would have lost in
2018. if you take this map back it
actually reflects the balance the the
balance of the state which is
this map would have produced roughly 60
40 outcomes which is the actual
electoral balance of the state federally
right now statewide state on a state
level my party does very well and
federally your party does really well
um but neither of us have
you know neither of us should be
entirely immune um
you know to the point about
governor sununu's first election in 2016
i believe he won by 1200 votes
and as his incumbency advantage as he's
been in office
his incumbency advantage has grown in
his service to the people
he's been rewarded with that and it's
hard to get a foothold when you can't
get in the first time so
and grow that incumbency advantage so
um that that is that is my definition of
competitive this is a district that if
you take it over the last 10 years would
actually represent the state 60 40. um
and your party i'm sorry i'm chairman
the party of the other side would have a
seat where they would more than likely
win not a guaranteed win but more than
likely win because that's what's been
happening
um
and that's my definition of competitive
and i'll even throw this out there
that's my definition of fair
further questions or comments
representative bergeron i'm sorry madam
chair
every time there's an answer to one
question another one pops in my head
um representative barry you're talking
about 60 40 splits approximately 40
percent of the state is registered as
unaffiliated or an undeclared voter
uh with the other 60 percent being
almost equally divided between
republicans and democrats
so
again uh you you use the phrase
reflecting the nature of of the state to
define competitive competitiveness could
i have something a little more concrete
and less abstract and
as to what maybe statistically since
you're a numbers guy uh you would define
competitiveness
if you wanted to representative barry
i'm i i am happy to define
competitiveness i just did i told you
it's based on outcome um to your point
about uh party registration
um
so i'm going to get a little in the
weeds here um my college degree is in a
is in a statistical analysis of american
political behavior
i'm really good at numbers
the majority overwhelming majority of
independent or unaffiliated voters
because i know the representative knows
we don't have independent voters we have
unaffiliated voters
are actually not
unaffiliated or independent the
overwhelming majority of them um
and in fact there is a direct
correlation
between how often somebody votes and how
politically informed they are and how
partisan they are and while they may not
choose to ascribe to a formal political
party label um i can tell you that the
staunchest conservatives that i know are
not registered republican because they
think the republican party is not
conservative enough but when they go in
that voting booth they ain't splitting
their ticket
the reality is is that
the overwhelming majority of these
unaffiliated independent voters while
they may not ever admit it publicly when
they get into the booth they do pull one
side or the other there are people that
do split their ballots and if anybody
who has ever been to a recount in the
state knows
split ticket voting accounts for maybe
10 of the state of the of the ballots
maybe 10
um
2020 might be the
might be the uh
exception that makes the rule in that
case um but split ticket voting in 18
and in the years before
was not rare but not common
so this statistic about you know a
plurality of the state is unaffiliated
and they're not they're all independent
voters they're not independent voters
you look at a poll they're actually
separated
independent voters are different from
swing voters they're different from
unaffiliated voters
if you're referring to swing voters that
generally speaking
and i don't know about the new hampshire
electorate specifically going back once
again to my degree
the swing voters are they change every
year based on the changing demographics
of a party and the and what the party is
presenting but they generally represent
anywhere from five to fifteen percent of
the electorate
representative lane
thank you madam chair
um it's a follow-up actually
representative bergeron's
question to representative berry
saying that competitive reflects the
nature of the state
would you say that you used that
standard when you approved the other
maps that have been before this
committee
representative barry so um as i said
earlier um i didn't draw
those maps
i drew this map this is my map that i
drew
so while there were things in the other
maps that i did not like
once again when we get there it's
effectively a binary choice yes or no
um
i'm here today to talk about this map
this is the map that i drew no other
hand went into this map this is my map
um so it's a fair point to raise and i'm
not trying to dodge the question but to
my point my point is i didn't draw those
it's a binary choice i have to weigh
everything with this i was able to
follow-up representative lane
you voted for them yes that's also i
voted for them so obviously i might my
vote fee speaks for itself
and we all have lots of those
all right seeing none i am going to ask
the clerk to call the role the motion is
otp the amendment is 2022 1702.
thank you madam chairman
representative steven smith yes
representative mcguire yes
representative turcotte yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn yes
representative barry yes
representative marjorie smith
no
representative bergeron no
representative lane no
representative gagne
yes
representative especia no
representative haken phillips no
representative talersky
no
passes eight to seven
can i vote i'm sorry representative
griffin
yes
does anybody have any other amendment to
bring forward as to s sb 200
i'm not seeing any so with that um i'm
going to say i would like committee
reports by two o'clock
pardon me
oh sorry we need to do sb 200 as a is
there a further motion on sb
200 representative smith
steve smith yep thank you madam chair
sorry i moved senate bill 200 archer
pass with amendment 1702h
second madam sure it's been seconded by
representative turcotte is there any
further discussion
that was the part i had gotten to
all right seeing none i'm going to ask
the clerk who is almost one sheet behind
okay representative steven smith
yes
representative mcguire yes
representative chaircott
yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lin yes
representative berry yes
representative gagne
yes
representative marjorie smith
no
representative bergeron no
representative lane no representative
piedra
representative haken phillips no
representative tolorsky
no
and representative espisia no
and representative griffin
yes
i do not believe there's any further
business for this committee at this time
representatives marjorie smith thank you
um
madam chair
um i assume that this will get on the
calendar for next week
um
and
then
tell me what happens after that does it
then go to a committee of conference or
does this bill then go back to the
senate
and how do we
how do we process that given the fact
that
this is a regular bill and would have to
be signed by the governor and the
governor has already indicated that he
um
did not think this got us to where we
wanted to be so does it go back to the
senate or does it go to a committee of
conference
where do we go from here representative
smith i know that you know the process
for this bill at this point you
certainly have many years of service in
this and i found representative berry's
arguments this morning quite compelling
so what the future course of this bill
as to outcome is i would never speculate
as to a bill coming out of a committee
in this house whether it's a house bill
or a senate bill as to what its ultimate
outcome is but it will follow the usual
course of bills as you know and it will
go to the house floor for
a vote and given that it is a senate
bill i believe it needs to get out of
the house by a date that has been
established by our body the house i mean
it will be sent to the senate for their
consideration and we will await
uh the decision of the senate as to what
they will do because we have certainly
amended sb 200 which they sent over to
us for some districts in april
so we will see how the process unfolds
as we will see with all the other senate
bills we will be considering on the
floor next week over two days
of session
anything further for the committee
seeing none this meaning is adjourned
and thank you everybody for coming and
thank you to our substitutes for repeat
um as i started to say before if i can
get committee reports by two o'clock
please
um i would think that you might be able
to use at least start from maybe
previous draftings
and christina is here if you want a
committee report from the previous vote
on this sent to you
uh for just ask christina to email it to
you and then you can decide whether you
want to make any changes to the
committee report for me to put in the
calendar
representative smith and representative
berry since you moved the amendment and
the otp can you two please resolve who
is getting me a committee report by two
o'clock
i thought it might be resolved that way
you